N
ISN'T DOING ENOUGH.
HE MADE THAT CLEAR IN A SPEECH
TO OUR CONGRESS THIS WEEK.
JOINING US, "BATTLEGROUND" THE
FIGHT TO DEFEND THE FREE WORLD.
GENERAL WILL BE ARE YOU READY TO
TURN THE PAGE?
ARE WE NO LONGER A SUPER POWER.
>> THIS IS THE NARRATIVE THEY
HAVE BEEN ON FOR A LONG TIME.
OUR TENDENCY TOWARDS SELF FLAG
FLAGULLATION.
WITH THE BELIEF WHAT'S GOING TO
EMERGE THE WORLD, WE CAN WORK
THROUGH THE U.N. AND
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS.
ALL THAT IS KNOWN SENSE.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT, RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN COUNTRIES THAT SHARE OUR
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES AND HAVE
THE POWER AND WILL TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PREVENT CONFLICT AND
RESPOND TO THE KINDS OF CRISIS
WE SEE IN UKRAINE.
FAR FROM IT BEING OVER, I THINK
WHAT YOU SEE NOW IS THAT THE
UNITED STATES LEADERSHIP IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO THE WORLD THAN
EVER.
BRIAN: I THINK PEOPLE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT.
I DON'T MIND IF WE MAKE THAT
DECISION.
BUT I WOULD HATE TO SEE US LEAVE
A VACUUM.
I THINK THIS IS AN HISTORIC
MOMENT TO REMOVE A CANCER THAT
HAS BEEN WITH US FOR 20 YEARS.
WE DON'T HAVE A RUSSIA PROBLEM.
IT APPEARS TO BE A PUTIN
PROBLEM.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THE UKRAINIANS PREVAIL.
>> WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE RUSSIA
FAILS AND UKRAINE IS VICK STORE
WAS.
VICK --
UKRAINE IS VICTORIOUS.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY THANKS
TO THE COURAGE AND SACRIFICE AND
RESILIENCE OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
I THINK BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING
WITH A HIGH DEGREE OF CLARITY
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS --
BRIAN: ON THE SCREEN ARE SCENES
FROM FRIDAY'S RALLY, THE  *'S
RALLY.
BIG CROWD IN A STADIUM.
DOES THAT SHOW YOU HE STILL HAS
POWER AND POPULARITY?
>> IT LOOKS STRIKE IN WEAKNESS
TO ME.
WHEN HE TRIES TO APPEAR STRONG,
HE'S A GUY WHO LIKES TO RIDE OUR
SHORTLESS ON HORSEBACK.
IT'S BRAVADO.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS THE COST OF HIS
INEPTITUDE, HIS POOR STRATEGIC
DECISIONS, MAKING THE WRONG
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT UKRAINE.
IT WILL COME BACK TO HURT HIM
BADLY.
WE HAVE SEEN THE NUMBER OF
CASUALTIES INFLICTED ON THE
RUSSIAN FORCES.
IN THE PAST HE TRIED HIS BEST TO
HIDE CASUALTIES, BACK WHEN WE
CLASHED WITH RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES.
IT'S HARD TO PREDICT.
BUT WHATEVER HE PORTRAYS
STRENGTHS LIKE THAT, THAT RALLY.
I THINK IT PORTRAYS PROFOUND
WEAKNESS.
BRIAN: AT THE SAME TIME TRYING
TO SUPPORT UKRAINE'S WIN,
STOPPING RUSSIA FROM WINNING
FROM UKRAINE.
THERE IS A DEAL TO BE
REVITALIZED.
IN 2015, WE DON'T KNOW ANY
DETAILS, WE KNOW RUSSIA IS
REPRESENTING US WITH IRAN.
WHAT IS GOING TO BE THE OUTCOME
AND DO WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT?
>> THE OUTCOME WITH BE
DISASTROUS IF WE REENTER THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
WITH RUSSIA AS THE GUARANTOR?
YOU ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
PAYOFFS BEING MADE TO THE
IRANIANS.
WILL THIS GIVE THEM MORE
RESOURCES TO INTENSIFY THEIR
LONG PROXY WAR AGAINST US?
YOU PLAYED THE CLIP FROM
FAHREED.
.WE TALKED ABOUT YEMENI, AND THY
ARE USING MISSILES TO ATTACK THE
EMIRATES.
WE DON'T WANT TO HURT THE
FEELINGS OF THE IRANIANS?
THIS MAKES NO SENSE.
YOU THIS ISN'T THE END OF
AMERICA.
IT'S A FRAUD ASSUMPTION THAT
IRAN IF WE WELCOME THEM BACK
INTO THE ORDER THEY WILL MODE
RATE THEIR BEHAVIOR.
WE FORGET TO CONSIDER THE RECORD
OF THIS PROXY WAR AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES WITH THEIR ARAB
NEIGHBORS.
THEY BELIEVE IN THE IDEOLOGY OF
THE REVOLUTION AND THEY ARE A
GOVERNMENT THAT IS HOSTILE TO
THE UNITED STATES.
BRIAN  * WE ARE SAYING WE DON'T
AGREE WITH YOUR CHOICE OF THE
IRAN OVER US, OVER THE AMMAN.
ALL THE COUNTRIES SIGNING UP FOR
THE ABRAHAM ACCORD.
SO IT'S THE UNDOING THAT IS
SUCCESS.
MAYBE BECAUSEDONE DONALD TRUMP
WAS A PART OF IT.
AND IT'S BLOWI